[Applause]
people are very confused Joy doesn't
come from four hour work weeks Joy
doesn't come from free donuts Joy comes
from firing [__]
and it's very hard because a lot of
times people that are bringing the
negativity to the organization are also
top performers
top performers come from two places
they're either driven by confidence or
they're driven by insecurity
most are driven by insecurity
insecurity then starts to manifest in
their day-to-day in suppressing others I
think it's very possible to have a work
environment where people are going very
hard but are very happy but I only think
it comes from the way we treat each
other I think the way you'll get to that
Joy is if everyone's nice to each other
and if you have the ability and the
conviction to fire the three people in
here that are [__]